were served full podcast welcome to the
worst of whoo podcasts we're here at the
were so full podcast every Friday
morning for you guys
sometimes Friday afternoon whenever the
manager decides to pull out the podcast
but it'll be out hopefully one day
before 9:00
shut out to Lisa Esparza who does the
wheel the steel and puts it up Aaron
over here chilling over here our silent
auction are over here with facts
sometimes so we don't even know what the
hell were talking about baseball facts
and we got word realtor is right here
from the Yemen podcast
yeah man Park have been going now for 38
weeks yeah 30 episodes also shout-out to
although other podcasts out there are
that we support or we support all of
them but some of them you know all
things comedy
we have Dino Raymond I heard he's
talking gene Simmons now word on the
street man Wow you get him on a podcast
Wow I choked you my turn my brother and
now George Perez George stories he's
learning all things comedy but he's
trying to be yeah man and Martina hooter
bro the yo yo yo podcasters Co yo yo yo
yo yo yo I tell you a story I was in
Chicago with your yo-yo with Martine
Moreno and Armando Co Co and and I think
I read good chariot humor you're under
45 that dude
and the first time we went there was gay
bro we are we went with to to another
restaurant called top of the G top with
a Jojo top of the g jo opposition Topo
Gigio
and um yeah so yo yo yo so we went to
this bar and we hung up with a manager
of Topo Gigio
this Italian guy and he used to be an
ex-cop
by the way right there in the city yeah
I hate to be an ex-cop but now he got
fired man he drove to another state with
a bag of coke or something done with the
word in the street says but now he's
just a manager at the top of GGO so he
invited us to dinner the first time I
was there with del daily Gracia and
other who go kuru man [ __ ] bro you know
Mexicans man let you know we love eating
dog
hell yeah then it was like especially
when this free you're not paying bro
forget about - you don't even worry
about the tip where are my a who gotta
kill give me another Fork yeah Messi you
feel bad you know that you could ordered
more knowing that you don't pay for it I
sure love Toto be kind so they bring
uproar like geez dude the appetizer were
like appetizers that used to be my main
dinner at the house they had where seat
those bro like I don't know we had um I
know the ribs big ribs but the little
runs to like riblets none of that
riblets they're like maybe back ribs I
know my minds to make them - they're not
be back ribs they're our neck bone my
neck bone well it's a slice that you see
the little bone right and then you have
to meet around it yes that tiny it's
been a so or some [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
anybody well that that was the appetizer
they were all in the bone bro with
little juices so it came that they just
pick it out and just suck it put the
bone back and we had hog hog balls okay
was that wasteful neck bones hog maws
isn't that like a like like the little
foot of the I was all Italian but I was
seasoned or Italian and then we ordered
our meal but before the meal my more of
that appetizer and more bread butter
olive oil olive oil and then the meal
came and B and in the milk a royal lady
brought pizza like what I never heard a
pizza number the pizza was like supposed
to be like like the another appetizer
brought flowers top pizza with a main
meal that's what I'm saying I really get
a salad or something some mozzarella
sticks I guess here food
I thought I was like oh like trying to
be I don't to be the get a 1 here member
man enough time
it's all I would like I would have the
only ghetto fool there or I know I
wasn't the only one I know max when a
pizza came I was like man all right man
who's gonna be the water a stupid gee
Joe we high that will you hide that
ranch they had wine in jafra whatever
the Kodak all jars cuz I'm the [ __ ] of
the table they help for [ __ ] bridge
pictures they have pictures of my
monsters you have pictures of wine but I
was just drinking water and soda
cuz I don't give two full brows I don't
think what I want to meet mr. on
anything
save it for the me so then of my meal
came you know bigos beginning for
cheese's delicious and and then I was
star full house time I thought I was
stuff but then it brought up this big
old plate man like this wrong plate must
have been two feet long or three Georgia
Lee man it was filled with ice cream bro
like simple like green ice cream
Amani spumoni like all over and they had
like like pieces of cookies or on me bro
and it brought up coffee thinking about
my family who started a you know like
when you grew up or you start eating
good but these are I eat too much a just
gonna borrow my mama's had them still
doing a project you can easily get Cydia
home eating like rats okay
she pretty much my dad and I cover less
[ __ ] psycho Sally she you know
cultural to install butter if your fancy
bro no butter and don't tip it over bro
I bought her fall on your hand they did
a circular arm but yeah man so though
dude it had cookies bro like well I nail
a wafers or something yeah good all warm
still
it would like to be scoria bro and then
that the little round tube that you see
in like in pictures in the ice cream
yeah man and um spumoni bro never had
ice cream at that before I thought I
could have been your policy at the
moment we - by when we were little
yeah the only reason I know about the
the spumoni is cuz I went to the
Spaghetti Factory the first time they
brought it out so I met the guy
well so he feels good anything I won't
come back kids come back I'll take here
you guys right the manager of Topo Gigio
said that man was so stuffed bro like
stuff bro and we're staying in a condo
one bathroom off our fat asses dog
I was so stuff and badge' near see they
mainly give us the arm they went to they
took it to a back room and they had
cigars for us if he wanted cigars and
cognac oh yeah I wasn't drinking mouth
when I me and I even took off to smoke
another blunt bro
walk it off would you just do a good
airplane ever it but I never had I never
had White Castle Oh a lot of fat fatty
food back there
oh jeez oh is it up exclusive the
shaitaan right here was right next to
they ninja cog oh yeah right well like
right next door dude mad fine Italian
yeah dude it was good that tells me that
every time Adonis shows up he she
graduated ass you know like that would I
thought good he the manager
so when I get back to the yo yo yo when
I went back I want to go look for that
marriage you know I trying to eat good
again right who I got the to later was
closing but um we hung out and he gave
everybody else a drink
he got me like a soda and he took a
picture with all the Mexican cooks he
was just telling me he this is my
compadre right you know some Mexican guy
you tell ya know Maribel last wait a
minute paralyzed and so that guy keep
going on till you get to the yo-yo bar
yo yo yo stop thinking it man what is
this Italian dude all Italian guys
taking it to a black bar you know they
keep saying yo yo yo and I thought you
said you two african-american bar right
so I'm thinking okay whatever
you're paying for the cab he was driving
us everywhere dude that night the second
time I went there there was no food
though but he just drove around we go to
the yo-yo bar and brother yo your bar
used to be a old fire station and it's
just a regular Irish bar and then though
I'm the manager shows up just six foot
two Irish fool bro like he look like
little more funky to [ __ ] fools or bro
like a Viking they hit the you hit the
man hands bro big-ass hands like your
dad has your head should get
construction man hands it's a hard ass
yeah boy [ __ ] off fat ass baseball like
a catcher's mitt God see you he saw us
he goes yo yo yo so he created the
beginning yeah I was Greek reading so
the bar is not called a yo-yo bar just
the owner always say yo yo yo ah so this
guy he was so cool bro he gave us food
took polaroid pictures of us put it
under the bar because all the Polaroids
everywhere and Chicago at that bar and
he gave me a t-shirt right he was so
drunk the owner of that bar he gave me a
pic a t-shirt of the bar he know you
know he was also bragging to um
you know man you guys don't know that
but they film Batman here well the first
Batman really they shot it right there
the one with um the original Batman
unknown and out the other one or the
movie the movie the first one who's that
one with Keaton no the other fool the
new one the new Batman ah with I've been
a flake the other guy you know we don't
know man how we gonna say Val Kilmer
George Clooney Christian Bale Kristen
blah night dark night they shot it right
there at that board really yeah so his
bar like in the corner right it's in a
corner I was showing you the name of it
but he gave me a t-shirt he goes um he
goes hero yo yo yo he was so loaded now
he said oh man your guy like you man you
know what i'ma give you X 2 e yo u ro yo
another yo yo yo yo
'i'm hospitality Chicago oh yeah in what
happened in that dude tapas is oh hi
ma'am haven't been back to zany no more
man you know me but I'm a vintage the
Schomburg improv I've been to Jose Jose
our weed street but I haven't been back
- no yeah but I was about my first time
there then the guy from Zanies Rick you
know that dog his name was a time I
don't know he's too alive we shouldn't
get Gable to buy his mercedes banz and
all that hard damn and yeah so that was
I ate like a king bro
Oh like a full-course mio ha ah that's
like isn't a real meal supposed to be
like 5 courses you oh you're eating like
King Lear dogs in special when the
stuff's made right heals people make
spaghetti or pizzas after house and kind
of sucks but you eat it cuz you know you
won't be nice when that shit's done
right oh my god
you know you feel you even feel yourself
getting didn't me the pasta there oh my
god fresh pasta never yeah I'm guessing
but yeah the pasta was good man wasn't
no [ __ ] for the old man with
mayonnaise you know that she's good
were so fool came maybe got we got a lot
of things ok here we go man first of all
he was shout out everybody who came out
to who had been watching the HBO special
right yeah man Jesus did the
announcement and that fist bump
boom and I want you to go do a show at
The Comedy Store kill Tony so yeah I
want to check it out go check out kill
Tony within Edwards
Felipe Esparza I'm Brian Redman
producing and Tony Hinchcliffe it's a
hose and they have a band but Jairam to
some guy named mom
Jeremiah Watkins Watkins yeah cool
they're a team and they were the wine
testers so I did that show and the guy
from speedy weed was there when it hooks
up our Fred Stoller it's Freddy Stone I
forgive me a box bro I wish I would have
brought over here but I drove here Doug
well you want some follow me home I got
stars
I got pre-roll alien
I'll give you three stars goddamn you
never had three stars in your life take
that what here you two all right
we speedy we'd shout out to that book
also shout out to a zone
each you're hooked up another package a
zone add flavors of Easton yeah is it
one of them like Sequoia orange or
something right yeah he finally came
through are you talk
he's talking something he gave me some
socks bro man with my fat ass that
diabetic legs bro
tight girl ankles put a bow just read
each one on my leg when I put it on his
head
ozone this weekend Friday and Saturday
October 6 & 7 Nashville Tennessee at
Jamie's that's right I'm coming to
Nashville Tennessee man we're gonna go
check out the country music Sunday
October 8th Huntsville Alabama at stand
up live Huntsville Alabama
October 12th to the 14th Edmonton
Alberta Canada at the comic strip can
you believe people about tickets yeah
Canada bro who woulda thought that would
have sold 81 tickets already in and I'm
not there for two weeks that's awesome
dude give it up for those Canucks that's
actually the next week on one yeah so
October 20 San Diego at home fries by
the bay and we tell you this shows in
San Diego is to open arena so if you
don't really want to go to the show are
you gonna do this charter a boat and
[ __ ] park your boat right next to it
watch my free you know pay more to
charter that thing also October 21st I'm
going to Reno Nevada at the silver
legacy casino catch me Rodrigo and Lisa
bowling October 26 Phoenix Arizona at
stand-up live not a regular stand-up
show
this is for the Arctic's comedy podcast
festival doing a live what's a full
podcast and I'll be doing a short set on
one of the stand-up shows they'll be
pulling together that night
check out Felipe's world that comes last
tour for other shows dates and the rest
of the year shoutouts shoutouts to all
the new listener who started listening
after they heard me on Bill Birds Monday
morning podcast was some fool
give me some bill burr bro yeah we got
that Felipe Esparza man crazy stories
man like a Tarantino movie shout-out to
Frank
oh shut up to our caterers who made out
of food for the HBO premiere party who
we had last weekend the ended of
particles Rick and his team Theodore of
particles on Instagram made the non
vegan food and taqueria Lavin Gansa Dom
began taqueria on Instagram they made
the vegan food vegan bill there are
people those man vegan bills yeah with
the consomme then it tastes good it was
bombed out have you have real beans yeah
yeah dude I love oily yeah not as oily
but just as good at that
I don't even know what I was gonna say
fake dude but I don't even know was a
vegan I thought they had the vegan went
apart but it was bomb he - it was good
huh I took some of that [ __ ] home bro
and I mean that's Bordeaux body-slammed
six tacos did you tell other ones to
work for the other why me with the
dishes good also man shoutout to Frank
aka your beer friend who made the vegan
pan dulce
and we game gansito metal be considered
bad huh yeah I didn't get one of those
but I got the bundle said oh that's it
oh yeah kazuto basically just jelly and
whipped cream and dark chocolate and by
covering it but yeah man these vegan
conceit those are the bomb if you ever
looking for like if you have a family
member with a little allergic to meat
pork or anything that animal products or
a mother or anybody that diabetic they
have to change their diet but still want
to be fat and eat like a fat pig hit up
on your vegan friend therefore make
anything vegan for you
also David of la Flor de Jalisco bakery
from the Puente that full hook through
our pan dulce and tamales and tamales
now we brought me with a good yes I
think somebody got him in the beginning
there was like [ __ ] Santa took him
how do they see I think this rectum real
quick shout out to all our listeners who
volunteer to help us do prayer
and clean up afterward Josephine
Villegas and her friend Karen by the way
man Josephine and her friend Karen
first of all Joseph he invited her
friend Karen and I don't think she knew
that she was gonna go volunteer right
oh my god my friend invited me to watch
the show unless you know I'm [ __ ]
sweeping also Gracie Armijo question
lady Sara Sara Johnny Rock and Sandra
for Barton the marching Rizzo for taking
photos thanks for pitching in with
everything we need advice uh-oh
shout out to our winners who came to the
party okay man orgy go Hannity bro there
you go down Peter Diaz Jeffrey Aquino
Griselda a velar Benjamin beret
Dominique Brooks Pedro Diaz Joseph
Estrada Daniel Garcia Alexandre Garcia
Anthony Garcia Salvador Garza a Manuel
Gomez Stephanie grimaldo
al McGee and Eddie Larios Rafael de la
rios vanessa lopez Mike Lopez Francisco
moon yeah
Jennifer munguia Jonathan neues Ian
O'Donnell Eric Vaughn Talley own Alonso
Perez Santos Perez Nathanael Peterson
crystal Peterson Edgar Ramirez Jose
Rango Moises Reynoso Omar Romero Gonzalo
Rubick Alba Alex sows Eddie chick Soto
Fredrik Trujillo Samantha Baltierra and
chick is from Washington
yeah the guys shake solo there for one I
take it to watch the premiere of the HBO
party net food as soon as he won he told
his boss listen man I'm a party gonna
I'm probably gonna join his conscience
and if I win I'm gonna show tomorrow
just letting you know he goes well hope
you win man and he wanted he booked a
flight to Seattle from Seattle to LA
hung out took off in left yeah man and
also crystal Reno bro yeah bro came
around Southwest left on Megabus bro
yeah crystal showed up and George
Perez meet my boy
also Joe Barone our friend at Southwest
hell yeah dude
hooks up the handicap sticker with a
running late so I could just bypass
everybody yeah and shout-out to Sergio
or take out the Sacramento also
shout-out to our I to reviewers hell
yeah dude mush d3d from the Bay Area D -
promotion down you are weather grazer
mugs at zero three one one USMC infantry
simple super fire Samba 1-knob our
Mexican Shawn Rustin study chef
Betsy Bureau at zero eight twenty and
that is our Jack Foods one shadows below
always I don't understand ma'am I'm glad
we don't have a regular radio station
where we will call in bro we're like our
LeBeau over here huh I know man let's go
talk to Becky Becky over there and you
know what about our turbo man
how many you been I'm doing that [ __ ]
did I was have to say 50 years dude he
put in a three can you pronounce Oh
Spanish right a name right [ __ ]
I mean you've been doing this for 35
years man it's not Rogelio it's wrong
hey Leo how many times gonna tell you
how to do it [ __ ] are LeBeau you
can't roll his arse
please i Roberto didn't realize brother
he probably ordered seven prison hits
radio show and prison I wish you 20
bucks if you research that something
like that's going on roadmap especially
when it goes down we have a special
dedication to Joey in Fresno who's
Heather I remember who then right now
residing in San Quentin um a message
this goes out to message in a bottle
there's no more sunshine for you company
no sunshine
18 for a bullet to Trevor Noah
no it's funny he's always like giving
out [ __ ] huh oh yeah Matt shoutouts this
Oh dog he's like nah probably even
oldest guy like he below ground bro like
he owned the comedy store before the
comedy store on the car
yeah what does it sound like Syros right
yeah was an Italian restaurant
it hasn't he owned the rights to a lot
of those oldie songs yeah man
Gretchen would want to get him in a
choke hold he's an enterprise yeah bro
started buying everything bro is like
one Italy come when that guy from when
XM was putting our comedy on needed
content right they were putting our
country from everybody not everybody got
paid man
really yeah bro I just found enough for
my team over there no bro he might not
get nothing you don't own them you don't
own the Masters to that CD more so cool
podcast was so full ad before I bring
our guests ah ah dude I'm ready to fly
dog all right gentlemen get ready we're
ready already it was enjoy a Coco you
know what I'm saying we got a very
special guest from Southern California
man Felipe take it over let it fly
that's right [ __ ] we're over here
chillin anybody either ha ha you know
what I'm saying in a better condition
I'm got a machine gun [ __ ] truck I'm
ready to kidnap somebody else
that's why I did a did the joyed via
podcast drove what's happening oh I ate
too many stars yeah yeah yeah yeah look
that took an uber broke when I got to my
house you know those stars
yeah how many 3 3 is too much so what I
didn't wait for them to hit me so I keep
taking them like Korean like 45 minutes
yeah fool when I got home I don't want
to know by anything bro I just sat there
for a long time I was like I was ill
having a heart attack
I was my leg was asleep but they don't
send a finger all cash I weigh 270 I sat
on my leg for a long time it should be
asleep it's normal experience
yeah my left my body bro no judging
myself you loser you fat [ __ ] are you
doing you're throwing your life away at
least 10 push-ups a day you haven't done
nothing so I said let's do it
so I did I had I need to burp there's
just a little tightness right there yeah
clear up the esophagus yeah
never again yes the gentleman we have
Yesi Ortiz from power 106 she's on
weekends from 10:00 a.m. to 3:00 p.m.
place to listen to her in a radio back
in a day when she first came on the
radio
really yeah that that was a while ago
here in power 106 yeah man I go way back
this is Chico this is Chico Oh Tino
I was a part of 106 in when first when
Tom Jay Thomas I was like what mid-90s
right there mid-90s to host the Latino
show telepathically yeah he wanted to
come the Latino Ronnie James sidebar art
LeBeau 75 years 75 years radio he just
hit the Guinness world record longest
career as a radio personality started in
1943 yeah man Wow
yes that's a long time I don't want to
compete with him is the only one I
really competes with him with what who
do does all these beside him Rodney on
the run Bobby does Bobby we're not
allowed to say bad words on the show we
yeah this bill run Bobby I don't think
anybody up those I'm oldies right
someone else uh but I can't remember
he's gonna kill me because I know I
think there is someone else's does it
okay in the southwest yeah yeah yeah
but it's all I you know he's spawned on
yeah and it's kind of like R&B now a
little bit spun off of yeah alright
LeBeau but our limos legendary oh yeah
all aboard legendary bro oh yeah have
you a fish he don't show I bet you they
that he's the kind of man or personality
or entertainer that does not show up
anywhere unless they give him up hand
him a paycheck oh yeah oh yeah
he comes out dressed like like money
buddy like mine
for real man I saw him pee and then when
he was shaking his penis I called in and
I got a dedication I did I did yeah back
in the ER like early 2000s I was dating
somebody then I was like I want to make
it so excited would you kill dedication
it was a dedication it was it was
genuine so anxious and he played that
for me
check this though you know knowing that
trumpet Kalia right uh-huh
Chapra Kalia that big ol show bingo show
at the Queen Mary now the Queen Mary
there's another show us that just I just
started to day bro competing with that
show is the one with chance rapper and
together
[Applause]
I'm doing a show I'm hosting it's called
trap Italia November 11 at the same
place where they're having I'm scary
nights at the North the headlining
Brenton wood Delfonics genuine genuine
of course on the Jackson we just meet
that uh show up for some reason I think
they're under steam they understand
they're on our show but then I saw a
flyer that show to do two shows in one
night yeah what's up with that yeah oh
my god that that is gonna last all day
blast immersive rasa because the other
show is showing Snoop Dogg snoop Dogg
too short Snoop Dogg Ramona yalla and
some other crazy [ __ ] how that's that's
like that's a different marketing spin
but ours gonna be the better one in the
gentlemen because we have free tacos to
a four o'clock oh yeah I love me some
free time we a bongos gonna be on that
Kongo trainer trainer ultra near okay
Madlib Madlib Evelyn champagne Wow does
she think that so yeah that should just
pop out of nowhere bro once the other so
it started really where's it at what
city that was gonna Bobby be know it'll
be a dumb I was gonna be a time Orange
County Orange County Fairgrounds and I
were wondering our show was supposed to
be at the Orange County those things but
that's was gonna really but then he
switched it to the Queen Harbor really
yeah so doesn't be November 11 so check
it out people tropic Ally on November 11
dealing north a genuine there finally is
Brenton would and our lobo will be there
though yeah get a check from britain
would that's crazy that's all that's
like the old radio wave of doing stuff
huh oh yeah but this because you know
the cross mixing the genres you see that
you've been humming radio i've been in
radio now fifteen going on 16 years how
did you did you always want to be a
radio no gosh no are you kidding i'm so
shy i was i wanted to be a nurse guy had
been knows i was forget it I was sorry I
didn't my parents wanted me to be a go
to the hospital business so I didn't
want to be in radio at all but I think
what it was is that I started I love
music man I was like I love music my mom
you know they think they didn't speak
English so like they listened to like
Michael Jackson and Madonna and Bee Gees
and like my mom learned a lot of English
that way so I was like
gravitated towards music you know it
always made my mom happy because at the
time she was beating the [ __ ] out of me
so every time some music was going on it
was like so like she was happy so I
wanted to do something that made me
happy and made me feel that way so we
can radio just kind of like landed that
way radio oh yeah man I've been told I
have a radio face
radio so you were born in number here in
California yeah I was born in San
Clemente San Clemente bro the first
border check you passed the border at
San Onofre what the big old things that
look like boobs nuclear plant naked gun
yeah yeah that's on the five and fought
Brooks on the fifteen well now when we
cross the border the first time see back
in the day back back when I was a kid
that's like I meant a border check
looking for it just agriculture bro it
was for Mexicans right so Border Patrol
to hang out right there
was the sheriff's right there thank you
many yeah that's the second border could
yeah and stop people so they just sort
of smooth on in the first time bro they
um the guy that was driving they let him
go and it took me my mom my two little
brothers to a little low a sale drove us
back to Mexico no way you guys got
popped the first time yeah damn and the
second time same being a different
different guy you passed the first one
but then the second way he's got we made
it all the way through twice and we kept
getting kind of San Clemente yeah I was
the one that was a second border but
that was a but then by that time man I
did the joke about crossing the border
my brother dressed up and I do it on
stage a party you guys got your
documentation yeah but yeah I don't know
that border stuff to exist yeah it still
exists but they don't after people in
the movie yeah I don't they don't stop
your papers they just do this super
suspicious ya know in the five through
eight supplemented the fifteen freeways
Fallbrook yeah they wave they just wave
do something BR ma'am what's been tough
in particular in Tibet demos to be it
all white oh yeah I mean I well I didn't
grow up in some climate that was born
there but like I lived in Laguna Hills
in Mission Viejo and everywhere time
every time I say that they're like oh
you were rich no I wasn't rich I we
lived in like we lived in a two bedroom
apartment with other family members like
we I thought if you had a house like you
were rich like I got they have a house
they're rich you know I mean can I curse
on this yeah okay yeah so I was like I'm
I'm not [ __ ] rich and it would get me
so mad I'm like I we we just my parents
wanted me to stay in that neighborhood
because they felt like okay these white
people this is a good school is a good
at place for you to grow up and get an
education but what was sucked was I
didn't speak good English you know my
first language was Spanish so I went to
take ESL classes in kindergarten and
when I was going to elementary school
like they made fun of me I got any I got
into a fight in kindergarten because
this girl didn't like my color my hair
cuz it wasn't blond and she pulled it so
I punched her in the stomach I remember
that it was in the girls bathroom la
Marina Elementary and that's what
happened a nice little white girl little
white girl like yeah I went to kids with
I went school all white kids and I was
like the only little Mexican girl and I
was like no one likes me and I think
that's what like I just kind of like
shut up shut down you know like no one
likes me and you know but I
my first instinct was to punch her in
the stomach and that's what I did don't
happen thankfully nothing I was like oh
my god I was gonna get in trouble I was
more afraid of my mom and my dad saying
something but no they didn't say
anything I think they were just like oh
we don't even know what to do either so
they we went back to class like nothing
like nothing ever happened cuz it
happened the girls bathroom yeah so
that's what that's why I was just like
you know what I this is like I didn't
really have any friends or like a you
know little nerd I didn't really like
talk to anybody
I was completely not popular whatsoever
like forget about Laguna Niguel bro they
didn't want you growing up in Santa Ana
huh yeah my mom no but when we needed
groceries we were going we taking the
bus it's a Santana so there I felt
comfortable like okay we're you know
there's a lot of people who look like me
right and I think for the longest time
like it was a great place to like grow
up if you are an athletic you know and I
was an athletic and if you were like
academically strong and I definitely
wasn't academically strong so I had a
lot of challenges trying to figure out
who I was and then finally when I got
into high school I saw some more Latinos
I was
Latinos so he just kind of all like you
know stuck together yeah we just kind of
think it was just that that was in
Laguna Hills Laguna Hills yeah did how
long did it take you to get out of
yourself like in second grade
oh yeah I was out there pretty quick
because my mom married an American okay
and he was teaching me English he would
be like this is an orange and I'm like
no not on her I'm like he's like no
Orange I'm like mom it's admin so Lisa
kid mataranka I mean Orange and it's not
out of time yeah I got here when I was
like probably five and I started
kindergarten because here my brothers in
June so I start out with all that the
bigger kid started almost a year late
then yeah cuz I started out like almost
a year behind I was always small dog
although huge broke mm-hmm and then um I
remember what I remember going just I
just came in guard and that's it and
that I don't remember like first and
third I don't know there was a SL know
the kid and there was they didn't put me
in it yeah cuz you but you seem like you
pick up English you pick it up pretty
fast huh cuz even this year you say
sometime with the earth science book
you're like only Only Fools from back in
the day like remember that [ __ ] cuz
there's some fools that were just
[ __ ] dumb I don't even remember the
books dude
but earth science I remember just seeing
the picture of the book that had the
world know in kindergarten all the way
bagging on fools yeah what did you do I
didn't know what I was saying about the
funny stuff bro you are my tow some kid
some kid goes down he said I'm he told
me something that he goes down that were
worth t-shirt he goes on you like static
closet mesh and that's water right yeah
he goes on and forgot told him yeah man
if Mohammed she wears this you let the
devil know some food that that I'm it
was like your mom run away
I took some kid I'm like your mom [ __ ]
you my get my run away and join the
hippies he works for the Brady Bunch
Oh Wyn hippie yeah he ran away to a
teacher oh my god did poor see kids are
brutal men but I'm young I guess good I
started school with a bunch of other
kids that were all Mexican too
I guess I never know there's not knowing
that I worship we're all gonna stain
with an accent I guess you know see no I
I was I was the only one with the
accident and like I try to change my
language like I try to pick up English
really quick cuz I was like nobody like
there's nobody here that looks like me
you know and then when I finally got
into high school and then I found people
that liked me I was like okay I feel I
feel I can be myself
the only one yeah I'm not the only one
now and but I I liked what I wanted to I
wanted to leave just too cuz I felt like
I need more I need more of my I need
more culture diversity Wow other you
ever been in a situation I had my life
man where I never know the only mask it
anywhere it's just a scary feeling
because you feel like cuz okay so you
know I was the 80s right so it was a lot
of like a lot of races well there's
still racism knowing but but in the 80s
like even more so officers look down at
you you were like stereotyped wasn't say
when you get like that mean white lady
starts talking she wears your papers and
all that was like for real back then
that was really for real back when they
didn't like yeah like I would you know
people getting I would I would get all
that so I was like I didn't like it I
didn't I didn't I didn't comfortable I
didn't feel comfortable and you know
like I still have friends who live down
there sometimes I go visit and like I
still sometimes I get the stares and
there's more there's more of us
representing down the road right but
still you could still feel like this air
like this this it's in the air you know
it's like analyte I don't know what it
is in the air yeah it's like I go down
there like down at the how you still
live here girl like I don't know how you
can still live here and she's like well
you know we make it work and I was like
okay you know I mean I got I got love
for my little street that I grew up on
because that's where all my my Latinos
were out via Lomas I love to via Lomas
so you know that little pole section
right there is where we were all just
kicking you know I mean that that
neighborhood right there was the only
Street you knew where all the Latinos
were right there and via Lomas
she said Kiki
that's the only time I felt like that
well well I would like the only one with
all the rehab bro yeah everybody there
was a heroin addict and I was just a
crackhead dog belong you were an outside
everybody loved 50 60 years old like wow
young 21 per day I would like to play
one of those and how long were you in
there for a year
well I remember like being like wow bad
like should I come back when I'm older
or what no idea
should I go live more live you feel like
an outcast huh
I felt like a good because he's getting
that story's broiling or with the prison
I love the bag goddamn yeah just like I
got out of high school my first real
real short yeah yes so I've been tough
huh yeah I like that beat up a bunch of
people not even feet of anybody I didn't
want my girlfriend's maybe but not me
but there were some times that you know
you just kind of felt like a like an
outcast times like it just didn't feel
empower I grew up listening to power 106
oh okay you know listening to art LeBeau
listening to like a bigger boy the Baker
boy satis of the Baker boys yeah I put
one little guy I don't know which one it
was
there's one that blazes and when it
doesn't but the one that blazes their
full bra when i--when Hill working in
Miami he picked me up in a hotel room
cuz Gabriel SL gonna do radio but he
don't smoke but I do go I'll pick you up
man he picked me up bro that for driving
with one hand put the wheel on his lap
and I'm gonna [ __ ] world up with one
hand good buy one of the best roller
well your deal the best roller but the
[ __ ] can't ruin one hand I've
rolled when I Drive they put it with one
hand
yeah put it like he put it right here he
laid it they wet his hand and he rolled
it dude a blunt
yeah that's Talent oh definitely talent
cuz you gotta focus I don't I don't know
if I want to witness that though
my safety driver you can smoke it fly
man there they are
hotbox so you are wouldn't you just that
when you get started like maybe heard
you get a radio maybe I should do radio
um I it was just I heard a commercial on
power 106 for a radio for radio
broadcasting school and so I was like I
think I could do that because I like
music I like radio and I was working at
a hospital and I definitely knew I
didn't want to do nursing or stay in
that field so I was like you know stuck
on the 405 freeway and I listen to this
and I listen to power all the time so
when I called it to school and it just
kind of happened
it just kind of happened and I went to
Vegas to party with a couple of friends
and I stopped by a radio station Oh sat
it was the radio station right across
the street sadly from where the Mandalay
Bay is that now where the whole thing
happened there's a radio station there
ha 9075 and j-cruise who's on our
morning show he was there doing nights
and his name was Jay noise yeah so he
was Jay noise and so I told he like I
called him up as a like you know crazy
la girl wanting to do shout outs on the
radio on the radio and so I was like hey
you know where's from LA he's I come by
the station we're you know right across
tree from the Mandalay Bay so I went
over there and he he was like so you
know you onto some shine from LA we may
want to get married and divorced the
next day and I was wild and so he was
like hey what are you trying to do you
know you want to be on the radio and I
was like yeah I'm going to school for
broadcasting but I think I want to do
radio he's like well we're hiring here
so I was like at the right place at the
right time and they gave me an audition
so I took the audition and I ended up
getting the weekend doing weekend
Saturdays and Sundays and then I was
driving from Long Beach to Vegas every
weekend to do my radio show
oh dedication that yeah that's four
hours therefore I was back where I was
there I would leave Friday night go to
Vegas be there Saturday drive back
Sunday night be back at work Monday
morning still work I'm still working and
going to school slept in the studio in
the carpool
I mean yeah I did that before out three
months and I was like you know I'm just
gonna fa I'm just gonna quit here my
hospital job I'm gonna finish what up
what I can from school and then I'm just
gonna go find another full-time job and
go move to Vegas so I just moved to
Vegas my parent my mom was like freaking
out like why are you doing that it's
only on the weekends that's like what is
this so I was like now I'm gonna just go
do it so I moved to Vegas I found a job
out there doing the same thing I was
doing in Saddleback hospital which was
admitting and then I would be on the
radio on the weekends and I didn't tell
any of my co-workers at that Hospital
that I was on the radio on the weekends
so it can't be kind of funny cuz they
would listen to the radio and I was
there Monday through Friday when they're
listening to the radio station that I
work for and then I would be on
Saturdays and Sundays in Vegas in Vegas
yeah yeah so I was doing that for a long
time I was trying to just be incognito
abadi new jobs yeah yeah yeah yeah until
I until I got hired full-time full-time
another yeah and then I got hired
full-time but Vegas did that mid days
and then after that I went to Tijuana
and I moved into the one I lived there
for about six months
well you do realty one in Spanish
bilingual it was hip-hop amaz blazon
98.9 what did you say like knowing they
also pulled on my blaze in hip hop I
think you how's that how was TJ was that
before all that [ __ ] was going down and
still going down but you crazy when you
were there yeah was the coach they were
doing a mayor a mayoral a metroid who's
I think grown at that time yes I think
no no orders got you yeah that's what he
corners he'll they've got to Felix right
salutely we're talking about this that's
all it's all phenolic
you know
google it so I'm right there it was
scary because I was there 7:00 to
midnight
I was working 7:00 to midnight and I'm
the only girl and mate at this little
radio station
besides the the other radio station that
was running mayor candidates on the
network and a journalist got shot and
killed like maybe two blocks away from
the radio station
you know they wrote something bad about
the candidate and got shot and killed
and I was like oh my god and we didn't
have many security like that you know
it's DeWanna I mean there's a fence for
real I mean just had I go home from
there too you know so back alone yeah
back then like laughter like a meme like
one of those President Trump
memes bro that write something that that
will get you killed in Tijuana yeah that
or just cheese me that's real that you
put out on the street would have gotten
you killed yeah absolutely
the real stuff yeah they don't want out
there Wow yeah it's it's no joke if
you've gonna write something if you
wanna put a joke about them it's
literally no joke they will kill you for
that [ __ ] it's crazy so yeah I would go
back to my hotel my little I mean a
little apartment I was broke AF their
opinion pesos they were they were paying
me in dollars but I feel like it was
equivalent to Bissell's cuz it would be
nothing they you know what they said
they were bucks a week probably less
than I was making $300 every two weeks
300 bucks every two weeks and then there
was times when they were like we can't
pay you this week we have to pay you
next week bro my rent was $300 oh my my
rent was $300 a month plus my $20 for
gas cuz he comes around the gas guy buy
your gas three hundred and twenty
dollars a month or pain yes and I
couldn't afford that so I was like man I
was mine that was six months of doing
that it was like came back asking No
miss Glenburn Beeville BJ Billy night
Billy
well there are other Americans working
in the relocation yeah there was a lot
of Americans working because the offices
were in San Diego so the only the
studios were in Tijuana and they kept
saying oh we're gonna bring them to San
Diego that never came so there was a lot
of other lot of other people but they
were staying in sending your station he
worked that was more like a border
station now so you could hear it my son
in theatre California yeah yeah yeah all
in San Diego no you can hear it all San
Diego most of the wanna and everything
but but mostly all of San Diego did you
get the true you have to get a work
permit from Mexico to work yeah work for
me and because you know um I I didn't I
couldn't run my own boards you know
hearing the state's you you run your own
board you put control of your own
microphone it all the way so in Mexico
you need a board certification for that
really yeah I did it was technical
another you see little mice to do a
little emphasis Cuomo know you press a
button in a clicks I can't remember his
name but he and I would get to fights
all the time I am yeah Yolanda yeah
pretty much she would try and I'm like
just wanna command a key held when you
may be home yeah nope Western oh yeah
yeah I was like together to walk through
the same coffee all day so I feel like
he must have been left in the real
station alone sometimes huh yeah because
um you know there wasn't that many of
them so he would be working although I
was it you work till 7:00 a midnight
yeah seven a minute I worked the grave
shift for midnight
- morning yes I did ghost tell me
they're writing a building but yourself
I know I did that in yeah I did that in
Vegas I did a graveyard shift in Vegas
last time before that even early in the
morning 5:00 to 10:00 a.m. nobody's
there on a Sunday morning you feel like
nobody's listening though like nobody's
listening like man I could say some [ __ ]
right now nobody's listening to the
radio that's weaker in a garage and then
I and then from Tijuana I went to San
Diego and I did mornings in San Diego
and the corners you got to give away
prizes to to premio was so ghetto let me
tell you love French it over the - huh
they do they love free stuff but we
didn't do a lot it we didn't have street
team like that but company it was so
terrible they're like we're gonna go out
and celebrate the launch of our radio
station right we're gonna take you guys
out to eat so we went to this one little
like taco spot in San Diego this full
pace with gift certificates from the
company keel it early had coupons
he was like we well it's a it's a coupon
so we can't really afford everybody so
we're just gonna give like a coupon for
your meal I think with buckles in can
you believe it I was like oh my god so
like they were broke it was so bad I was
like I need to get out of here they were
using those two things wasn't taking the
cash hit here no no you're embarrassing
you mean you came you wanna I left my
house in sequin across the border over
here to come to San Diego for a free
meal that I thought was gonna get which
by the way I'm already broke as [ __ ] and
I need a free meal you and make me have
it with a discount coupon come over here
eat her story reminds me of when Howard
Stern
you see the Howard Stern movie right
when I ran in radio for that Lebanese
guy he was mean Howard he goes I like
you Howie you hear a time every day I'm
a promote you to producer all right well
it pays $250 a week
he goes alright first job fire him but
thanks I have a family you know you're
the family you know here the family
Howard he's gone a year gone mirror you
you get promoted at that we saw the fool
leave yeah like took the 1 spot in
Mexico at Diego and I all do have to
leave no the old that we play somebody
did I replace somebody I did in San
Diego I replace somebody in San Diego
yeah and we play somebody in LA and I
felt bad but in a layman Amato I deleted
technically Mexico work this place is
that work that way though you go to a
town bro that's all Union uh-huh
man you bring a [ __ ] taco lights yeah
you can't you can't it's not being even
at every decisions it's nothing yeah
they're serious about that [ __ ]
so you move to San Diego must've been
like man I'm glad I'm out oh my god
finally thank god there's a corporate
chick attached to this comes from
payroll comes from payroll I have an HR
department ago yes it was so
life-changing for me so I was it was
like I can finally afford tacos brokers
it was so bad Philippe but you have no
idea I was driving a little Gio you know
nine to me 1992 Gio was yellow
convertible so sometimes they call me
Little Miss pacman and the convertible
had yeah and the convertible had duct
tape holding the sides of the you know
cuz it was the sides were ripped so they
had duct tape holding it together
she had a hootchie mobile tents had a
better launch be in that car white tail
on there the red tape over the brake
light I know I thought that maybe you
wanna pick some people a red bandana
d.school I see not the worst thing I've
seen you know red tape on are now on our
brake light is broken I seen a red
t-shirt before Oh red t-shirt whole
other level bother I've seen a
flashlight in the headlights I'm there
from two years in San Diego doing
morning's become popular in the morning
they're big words we didn't have
billboards we do we have to cut the
corner we have flyers
I was so excited with papas in beers no
Club no light oh oh yeah so you were
there at the events in the big week
dance in Mexico when you were there like
it's another now that oh sorry thought
he got crazy crazy it was a banana
military and regular people on the radio
because San Diego now I'm on the radio
we got corporate money we're at Papa's
in beers you know we're just partying I
felt like damn this is dope I'm like
living life but then you got no check at
the end of the week funny Toro Toro yeah
a total Air Force Base yeah where they
had the air shows yeah we're man I was a
- I work at the air show one time in
Otoro I was also poor I hated life I
wish I was a DJ iguana buzzers bro
in the hot Sun there's no trees in sight
and then I have one buyer that she'll
rip bro
on my head and she was thirty dollars on
April are you serious I was that one
minimum wage was like six dollars yes
okay I thought
dynomite brought three clean up the
chicken coop oh yeah peachy
so that died you know we the people that
were working with we were all employees
of Dodger state and I we were selling
merchandise at Dodger Stadium this guy
named already took us to he made a deal
with the thing so we're selling buyers
it brought nobody by no [ __ ] adviser
bro and that sucks
so that we said hey guys we're gonna
take water Mexico what to go some of
these kids were not even eighteen or
twenty-one dude right I was barely 19 I
was 20 years old that's back in the day
whenever we all went a Mexico fool all
over you're lying on it's a bad news
bears bro yeah van all dirty boy we go
to Mexico I'm 18 jumping on the bed we
were gonna be there for one deal and we
everybody splits up was a turnaround
trip yeah everybody splits up and I'm
hanging out with one dude and I have it
and I have a my we had margaritas bro
you're lying I went to a bar I wasn't
even 21 or jumpy margaritas that's a bad
man I got my my head will fell hot I was
buzzed then it was a guy named Cobra
from Echo Park how you you married your
memories really good he was yelling what
happened how we lower somewhere right
now are the Lita's go to another cheap
part when it's around the corner yeah
and he oh he didn't have there's a $60
broad not even wanna pay her
so the girl was like 48 with her beating
his ass really it's gonna run out so we
went over there bro and we helped them
and F we took off Dan and then we cry we
walked the border we couldn't find the
right so we just crossed the border
walking and for sooner we got to though
we saw this drunk as marine growing no
ID
no nothing bro like his shirt was
missing he had to a crazy fight he'll
can you help me out I'm trying to make
it back I love my idea bro just cross
the [ __ ] chains but I'm military to
give [ __ ] up back they
I don't know if they still do it yeah I
don't know they still do but back then
it was crazy
I've only went to a TGA like twice to
party in really party because life guys
come around with the whistle and not
anybody with that cheap bastard Kela me
released I saw got the [ __ ] your toga
party at least a pass by and - you mean
from comedy you go hey bro your dreams
nah man my wife does who he gave her a
shot then he give her some juice another
shot then you [ __ ] shook her bro oh
my god I knew you were gonna shake it
but Isaac didn't know today's Babu right
there see this Bob act like a hood right
[Laughter]
I think looking at Lisa like to be a
knight this is what you do and you do
see therefore with the dirty-ass hands
making the food dog carburetor if we got
here I'm gonna give that for some period
when you usually when you get to the
corner saw the barbecue late
that made me sitting right there in the
Sun by itself bro yeah you gotta be like
a fat guy bro like mondo so San Diego
man so you was like when they started to
make the move for from leaving your job
and doing it full-time for me I was
working two jobs to I working from 7:00
in the morning to a three o'clock
security guard at in Sylmar they never
come out of work and
so they said I make it to Dodger Stadium
by 4:30 to wear that to work yeah yeah
I'll get out at midnight no 11 o'clock
at night and then I would drive to the
comedy store to go up at 12:30 and Wow
that's a hustle the reason I quit my job
was the only because I'm looking for
child support [ __ ] that if I could keep
it on nobody can I'm probably taking a
mad chunk we've got a hard decision to
do that to finally quit your nursing job
well I wasn't well I wasn't in the nurse
I was in the admitting office but the
Barbizon
I was just in the admitting office with
medication yeah the front pretty much
like the front office in the pharmacy
tooth but the complainers you get huh Oh
all day all day but you know I didn't it
wasn't hard for me too quick his
something told me that I wanted to do it
and then so I'm not a nine-to-five
behind the desk type of girl I'm just
not I just I just not and I figured that
out once I figured once I got word that
I got the job in Vegas to do radio I was
like I'm out you know like I'm gonna do
this for three months and try to figure
out where I'm gonna live and how I'm
gonna survive but I'm out cuz
nine-to-five job is not for me you know
it just wasn't so I had I didn't ever it
wasn't really too hard it was sad cuz I
felt like I was leaving my friends and
my like family but no something apart
once they just started power 106
I started in Vegas but then you got
hired no ioveiy gas Tijuana San Diego
and then I went to power 106 so when I
left mornings in San Diego I left and I
came to power 106 and I at that time I
had already took in custody of all my
nieces and nephews so I had taken care
of them
Wow six of them reality show rate you're
working on right no I'm working on a
scripted series single with seven single
was seven was a reality show that I did
it was a pilot it was a doc you part of
a docu-series that I did so that
wouldn't that one already aired that was
a couple years ago that's one that was
on Nouveau that was on mundo
mundo and Style Network which is no
longer around but it was a part of a
docu-series so like now I'm working me
on a scripted series
how many kids six often the one system
my one sister yeah she had six kids and
I took in all six of the kids when I was
in San Diego so when I was there it was
a Bernie Mac huh we said he have six in
the show oh he did yeah so I had six at
the house three boys and three girls and
a Brady Bunch
we were the the Bruno branch the Bruno
Bunch is what we call ourselves radio
that's the story of the yes II bug
that's a good reality show opener Yeah
right a Brody with her my sister just
couldn't get life together man she
present no so the parents the mom and
dad they were into a domestic dispute
and the kids were involved some way
somehow and so the kids got taken in the
foster care system and they went to jail
the dad was in there three strikes
you're out rule so he was going to
prison and then after his five years
that he had to do he was gonna get
deported to Mexico so he was like like
there's no way I'm never gonna get my
kids back like it was a bad hombre you
know it's a bad hombre um during that
time he's changed you know for the
better now but living in Mexico he's
living in Mexico still yeah he still
doesn't wanna but did he come back no
never ever
no three strikes you're out so the and
then my sister she got out of jail but
she wasn't supposed she wasn't doing
what she was supposed to be doing to get
the kids back and then you know she got
involved with drugs and then that kind
of lost her way and then she just kind
of you know I was one of those things
were like she's not gonna come back from
this any time soon either
so like my brother angel we all have we
all have somebody that we can relate
this to
- and her family right like oh that
reminds me of my prima so-and-so or when
you see my daddy - it's not for other
people - people your family always ask
you for your roaches for your family not
my use my brother my brother I use my
brother's name because I got arrested
and I have more wars in me bro no way
yeah later on when I was trying to run
for Last Comic Standing that forgot
arrested and use my name bro
[Music]
my sister take my identity identity when
she got um she got caught for stealing
and I ended up getting a bench warrant
nobody believes you I was so pissed
did you get cleared up or not yeah I end
up getting it cleared up but I had a
like go through [ __ ] stress and go
through a public defender he's like look
you can I go to jail my brother for my
brother potty on a special we do you
still talk to your brother's my brother
gone mad nobody know the Iram he
thinking about with your kids real daddy
in Mexico and their full age my brother
um he took my brother's identity
bothy the guy I talked about in my um my
in my eye I'm gonna see a real name but
somebody else do it right now well party
they took my brother stolen identity
committed crimes right one day my
brother I don't know where you know he
get stopped for a moving violation they
got wrong his ID he comes back the food
takes out his gun has up in here you're
under arrest for such and such and such
all right my brother couldn't clear his
name at the county jail in our lane he
couldn't clear his name in the judicial
court now for got sent all the way to
Eloy Arizona bro with were though for
getting ready for deportation
you gotta read he they sent him with
other
immigrants or undocumented occupant you
know what's crazy fool he's probably
saying dude it's not me I didn't do the
kind and everybody that's locked up with
him yeah we heard that story before this
was straight and narrow man straight in
there oh look a good citizen luckily
when he's home he was locked up he
hooked up with a guy named shout-out to
Danny Danny the homie this guy named
Danny he was in my rehab bro when I was
in rehab but that fool never stopped
using drugs when they were locked up oh
yeah yeah you are a real name right
finally somebody believe me no and then
what and how did your brother end up
getting a - and that other fool just
using those names so he doesn't have to
spend a night in jail huh putting what
time we were driving I was good to ash
or a brother when I were all hyegyo's
man because man I was just which lies
with you go back to your special you
know the picture of you all three you
its Ange on the left it's your brother
partying you parties are happy you're
all smiling and that other little fool
you can just see these are devious dog
yeah trying to hatch a plan yeah my
brother holding him though family she
see Joey working a new show yeah so now
I'm working on a new show is scripted
series loosely based on my my life
because it's like you know sorry new no
I'm not an actress definitely not an
actress I'm just more behind the scenes
you know so we we have um thankfully you
can yo database we've had meetings with
him and he's going to direct the pilot
once we get it sold
oh wow I know you're pitching new people
yeah we're pitching the people we had
meetings last week we had NBC CW Fox
they said no bye
we still have like lifetime YouTube
Bravo
that's that's I'm hoping Netflix would
be another one who else we have I think
we have like a couple other broadcast
networks coming up [ __ ] season y'all
know how that works when we met and on
the power 106 and I was doing numb
you're doing my sister station 93 5kd
yeah si si si si pass of mucho go faster
bar our show could output you know show
last year and you know have you got to
the point where they tell you while
maybe um maybe will be good for your
show if I'm one of your relatives is a
ghost
no [ __ ] how about I remember mom
sometimes you gotta go in to a meeting
with crazy idea bro just oh when you get
to the final pitch you take out the
crazy part take out the crazy yeah you
finally go to listen man um later on
somebody watching television hey
whatever to the neighbor playing with a
vampire goalie now he's Salvadorian now
they told me that the neighbors of your
vampire I didn't know how these pitch
meetings work bro that's exactly how I
took it was waiting with a kami with
they gave me the pitch the pitch pages
and I was changing [ __ ] lifting right I
was like no we're not gonna call my
character you know Jesse mighty icons I
blah you know I'm like no where am I to
do this and I knew that my name became a
cheer thought I was like taking all
kinds of stuff why do we gotta leave why
do we gotta be like immigrants from the
blah blah like like not that there's
nothing wrong with that but I just felt
like they were so stereotyping my who I
was and what my story was I'm like we're
not doing that like this is a real story
and I'm latina and I'm proud of it and
you know we've had enough and I'm not
gonna [ __ ] go in there and talk like
Sofia Vergara like I'm just not because
I don't talk like that
yes I think I do yeah they show me your
tits peach yeah and show me that yes
like it's crazy how about um um we don't
really say your sisters like a drug
addict and we say that um she's uh
working abroad somewhere and she's away
from a family I know I know I know
on our Red Cross machine and she can
really take care of the kids so you
gotta take care of oh yes a better
course he's on sabbatical did you throw
anything man just to like and what's all
that [ __ ] for dog I don't know it's
super you wrote me you guys have been in
meetings so you you know how corporate
in Seoul like let none know not much
diversity at all diversity when you came
in the world uh Mexican security yes see
the building you coming up in here like
yeah like when I go to Universal and I'm
Shirley Nam one scene only like two
lines embassy yeah for Cody Ryan
superstore and I walk in there bro and I
execute it but what's up [ __ ] about
walking to the stair but [ __ ] that bro
you know actually I'm a walk you yeah
I'm walking in [ __ ] and then another
time this guy recognize me well we're so
full on mammal in addition [ __ ] that
broke getting my little golf cart
I'll Drive you or drive you this they
were like where you have you parking way
over there yes you're not uh huh you
gonna park right there VIP sure enough I
walk in I'm like that's my people I wish
you're buying that manner and the other
act the regular people in the cast the
chippy now they say why is that why are
we so excited it's like hey Tori is so
happy today
called Street love
man why why their team today Philippe is
here everybody that was making food and
security guard even Trenton came out bro
when I was eating and I just took photos
everybody and then like all the other
like the cast member or like all right
that's how it is a trip trip I know and
I'm just like down this is it's so sad
how disconnected sometimes people are
but whatever it's all good so you try to
break barriers so you're gonna pictures
your show this week or yeah this uh this
week I have I think I have lifetime this
week in Bravo and then next week is
YouTube but there's a couple other
networks that we have lined up still the
own network that's funny men and life
time how about the six kids murder you
know life time where I go watch women
get killed
honestly the show doesn't like Daniel
likes this show and it's great that he
wants to be on the project and he's been
so good write him an entire entire team
man three bus but the if this doesn't go
you know then that's fine cuz I'm gonna
just fine
my people so fun do what we got to do to
fund it and keep it pushing and tell the
stories that really represent and break
stereotypes cuz that's what I want to do
I want to be an advocate for that I be
telling the same old story on that's not
telling the same old story like oh okay
he crossed the border he now he works at
this you know blah blah blah and you
know it's like there's guess what we're
more than just I know just construction
workers we are lawyers where doctors
were entrepreneurs where business owners
were were way more than what television
has continued to portray us oh yeah I
just watching that uh that like what's
Jill in a Jake that uh when we were out
between on an Adam Sandler and the
Mexican do they have their like you know
the gardener didn't really look Mexican
but I was like well Jack and Jill
another team and I would like to have a
Latino show where we're at the end of
the episode there's no message for
nobody can black and Latinos have a
television show where there's no message
where there's no deep with a deep
meaning behind it we have a show where
at the end where we're not talking about
moving to somewhere better
we'll just be there already
staying at the Jefferson good times they
want all their whole episode about get
moving at the projects moving out the
project I want to be the Jefferson Luke
Torres he's to do the whole song of
baram 4-barrel e-beam belly's stay right
back after about wanna pour the one did
he get hit by a truck
no they call up Jerry Nicole every
partner in the [ __ ] ring
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thinking about that man like when you
watch so regular like white sitcoms you
know the white shows there's never a
message for nobody just a show this is a
comedy show
living single just a bunch of chicks you
know you do better did you get the
message
[Laughter]
yeah we're supposed to be better better
like leaving
oh that show that Bill Cosby to have
after Arrested Development now Bill
Cosby bro now the the I know it's a
college the college one yeah it is
something a different world a different
world
yeah morality we think about that was
the first show ever where black people
going to college
Manny was saying man I went to college
man who's just out that showed me yeah
man I put put to that time they haven't
been any black television show where
black people in college yeah and that
like enable a lot of people to be like
well it's all right I'm gonna call is to
get a GI Bill yeah absolutely
but now Latino we're making progress
right now we have a show on Hulu where
there's two in high school
what's that show its high Oh II slow
sighs that's right I think Gilbert's on
that show
yeah man where every problem is solved
with a dance contest I have been seen
the show so I'm gonna go ahead and trust
you you're saying there is that for real
first to see this our pilot more hard
core as one yeah you get a hook right
away yeah yeah and then a third a fourth
I rode for the third Airport what I
wrote the jokes oh you did I took a lot
of cold cuts out and I changed them too
or they were saying skunk us in the
script yeah yeah it's calm oh geez
yeah oh geez man hey what son what's the
new term now hey what do kids have a
different term now are they not used
because I know they're not using skunk
ass and their nineties you cheese using
trap ho see a trap ho ho Instagram star
oh yeah IG model yeah insta ho yeah
insta ho but felt like there was
something else which is to drive hundred
cords
Synnex civics huh Geo Metro so fool
people find you a real jingle you can
find me at uh my Instagram Rodrigo
Torres jr. you can help find me at my
Twitter handle
Rodrigo Torres jr. and on Facebook yeah
we show it's coming up right now so
Huntsville in okay yeah we events coming
up I do can I talk about the auction
okay tell them what they're gonna win an
auction for the relief efforts of
meheeco important Rico Oh
so dude they got like people people are
forgetting that puerto rico's basically
gone it's so crazy me and in mexico
Morelos in oaxaca got really bad
earthquakes unfortunate that many people
died there from this earthquake so we
want to do a relief effort and I've got
some really great things to auction off
it's a silent auction Felipe for tickets
to his show and I thought the Ontario
improv and meet-and-greet meet-and-greet
- free t-shirts and one vinyl album yes
it's a double platinum double album and
I just Georgie go man and listen to it
right I got one copy right now
and I put in the records Barstow 15
minutes each side so it's our two two
records yeah that's amazing so we're
gonna auction I don't have that many
release that person holding the
collector's item right there
that's okay so now you know so we have
that we have Jane the Gina Rodriguez got
a gave us a script of Jane the Virgin
and she signed that we've got Luis
Guzman
lunch with Luis Guzman you said you
smile I want to get that Yeah right come
over and before it oh yeah man yeah bro
would have lunch here at the podcast go
[Laughter]
Kerry Washington she's sending some
Stover if you found a hip-hop you got
common we got logic we got kid ink we
got all kinds of items that they donated
from them personal like for them their
personal belongings and collections if
you're a Dodger fan we got fans for
Dodgers of you an NFL fan sports fan we
got so many dope stuff because we get so
much dope [ __ ] that we keep it in our
closets and we have their exclusive
limited items so why not try and give it
to the people bid on it and the money
goes 100% to Puerto Rico Mexico
like that's it it's so easy where's the
where's the silent actually gonna be a
like a like it's on in Koreatown do you
guys know where that is
it's like the best Oaxacan restaurant
they make the best big mural of the
little girl no rooster yeah I've never
been there but I passed by there yeah
what's one Hawking food bro it's a lot
of that's where I come from okay
it's bomb so shout outs to like I like
itself from the greens right like the
ones that are made out of like cactus
yeah yeah a little a little like a like
a bowl of cereal to eat to a bowl of
cereal yeah I saw that the Hawking for a
meal no I let my in owe me or something
Oh probably it's funny that you bring up
not funny but Mexico City suffered a lot
of damage but Oaxaca is to the curb man
yeah so it's a lot of them not getting
too much attention no not at all bro but
let me tell you that's sad I just have
to brag on how dope these women are that
are letting us use their space at the
restaurant because they're giving us a
space from 7:00 to 10:00 on Tuesday
October 10th that's when the silent
auction is but then after we finish the
silent auction they're leaving to Oaxaca
to build houses so they're doing it for
real oh they're doing it for real for
real
money down there you know they
themselves are like no we got we got our
cream we're leaving we're going to
Oaxaca cuz they're from Oaxaca honest or
Oaxacan restaurant and inside the art
you know it's just so dope man and so if
you can come through bid on some really
dope [ __ ] and one more thing one more
thing one more thing sorry I'm gonna
give it to this so I got my friend who
made these right so I'm gonna give you
one I'm gonna give you when they're
stickers thank you so much they're
stickers so they're little my friend
made this design for us on Mexico and
we're gonna be giving these out as well
with any cash donation you want to give
out so this is a limited-edition sticker
that my homegirl Beck's did for me and
now she's gonna be October 10th Tuesday
October 10th from 7:00 to 10:00 at La
Jolla gets a and you can you could have
bid ladies and gentlemen for the Felipe
Esparza four tickets to the Ontario
improv in December and I'm with four
tickets to any
oh by the way not just Thursday or
Friday or Sunday this show sellout
Adam meet-and-greet yeah Pete you during
the show before the show starts I said
I'll take a picture with you you could
kill a roach with Rodrigo and that
exclusive limited vinyl you buy no
matter vinyl you- vinyl and a t-shirt to
t-shirt t-shirt uh no that must happen
Shiro Judah went through in a year man
turn me little packaging that's dope man
that's really generous thank you yes
thank you
I'm gonna get joy Medina bro to donate
one and boxing gloves or the dress from
a matador what's up food list of let's
tell them again October 10th at the
Hocking restaurant on Olympic wasn't
like I like it son
like that I get some yeah and only that
they're building a lot of stuff man
people I bet you a lot of radio stations
and especially well they're power 106
but I looked around a lot [ __ ] I want to
take I bet you got yeah you've been to
our office easy stuff like the posters
the posters alone bro are good to take
that the old concert ones yeah we have a
big-ass poster that Mariah Carey signed
huge it's for fantasy one I think it
won't get that form account if you found
a Cypress Hill Pharrell DJ Quik Ice Cube
we got like so few a vinyl head we got
all that I'm telling you it's dope as
[ __ ] October 10 will do your town I
believe was so fool where can they find
you ad on the Internet
at yes your piece Yesi Ortiz calm so
breezy and I'm part 106 out 10 in the
morning to 3 she gets to sleep in now
one more kid in high school senior year
so I said earlier good upper radio ever
when you're working radio 4 a.m. that
was doing mornings where I am every day
yeah it was no joke it was morning drive
radio yeah yeah my my idea no bonus
there no life no life exactly
grandma no life oh man you working in
Tijuana man welcome to Tijuana dude just
get though how you would get paid we
can't pay you this we can't pay you this
week we have no trash can but you could
burn you right there it was so bad
good questions anything you learn from
broadcasting school that helped you to
do radio in radio or keys honestly no I
think terminology is probably the only
thing that I really learned was the
terminology what a stop set is you know
but other than that everything no
disrespect to the school but it's just
honestly you can you just have to have a
personality or a man to each person you
can't teach personality that's it you
could teach terminology but you can't
teach personality right you can't bro
you can't this can be a staff on the
radio the butcher in sports back in the
days the news is some boring ass guy
today what happened in Los Angeles or
switch real where now I don't know what
he was saying switch real I didn't know
he was like really saying switch Rios
because they were gonna show footage of
the game yeah so switching the real on
Katie the okay did the guy will do the
sports a black dude Jay Thomson or
switch will the Raiders who just won the
game or name switch real then you go
back you work before you go my
everywhere station like the
stereotypical station where everybody
has a goofy ass name and there's a cow
bells and and bird noises Bellini
Umberto Luna de la Luna yeah he was
funny
I think in in every station that I went
to in every market there was always
somebody like that there was always
somebody trying to be that character and
then when I do these broadcasts like
let's say like you know MTV Awards or
like the radio rooms that's what they
call the radio there's always next to me
with like relax on the corner know where
hey you know I mean like they just turn
it on man that guy was busy brother you
turn with a guy in in in Iowa oh my god
Milwaukee mando then you go to he goes
to another room he's doing like English
[Laughter]
for somebody no no one on power 106 back
and a room that one voice yo what's up
man it's a Theo
yeah I even knows a Filipino dude I
simply zebra when the white guy is is
I'm playing a black girl give it up for
Shannon eeks Wow yeah the GAO just show
up and do like a girl black girl boys
and then leave I grew up banning to Lala
on the radio yeah were so full podcast
well G go torrents in the house yeah
many question for yes Ortiz that was it
just a broadcasting question man
would you recommend for any young
listener out there they want to get into
radio would you turn to how to get into
it honestly like start somewhere else
don't think that you're gonna start
right away in Los Angeles like that's
not gonna happen that's a prime market
yeah like if I were you a future if you
want to really do it your radio thing
like and then there's a on-air position
that's open in Kansas take that job in
Kansas like gold you know make your
mistakes go learn the business gold
experience it and understand shake hands
kiss babies do all that stuff to really
really understand the game and then make
work your way back you know I had to
leave to come back so I left and I came
back yeah yeah you know people do they
kiss at family oh yeah oh man there's
some Street teamers at our station that
they're like oh we we we stars already
like bro calm down the joy the same
k-rock bad for ten years yeah man keep
posting them bills and it's no
disrespect but like you got to put your
dues in you know you're gonna work hard
work really hard one thing I noted in
radio is that it changes fast yeah I
mean it changes so fast that one day
you're in the morning the next day know
your keys don't work so to the people
have been in radio been in radio for a
long time yeah yeah I'm like I'm really
lucky and blessed to have been there
that long and hopefully my contracts up
in February so we'll see you I stay
there stick around I hope so y'all want
to put in a petition for me only with
her right now we'll have Ruben and and
Ruben and Lola they're coasting right
now he's telling love dots on the coast
we have marks Thank You Reedy right here
and now
right now we have Rodrigo Torres right
now who's coasting in Santa Barbara who
wants to give a dedication to his
beautiful girlfriend who's coasting in
up when t shoot ever was my first job
let me tell you man
well jiggle having a good time he's
cheetah lady right back at the occasion
why are there together so yes you're T's
power 106 from 10 or 3 or G go Tory
man podcast weather was so full podcast
we're number night we were not we're
number 100 we were number 55 last week
by the way still really we're number
that we were there was 55 comedy podcast
everything dough yeah well charge today
Congrats
we're number a hundred right now yeah
[ __ ] yeah yeah man we were on
Billboard's podcast and and then Joe
Diaz and that pushed us to number 53 on
your special day
keep watching the special thank you very
much go to you guys